And hello hearts of oak. Thanks so much
for joining us once again. I'm delighted
to have our favorite Can we call you an
Islamophobe? I don't know. Robert
Spencer has been with us many times.
Robert, it's always good to have you.
Thanks for giving us your time today.
>> Peter, always good to talk to you. Thank
you.
>> Not at all. Um, and you've got I'm sure
we'll have you on later on the year
because I know you've got a a book
coming out November. And I love the
title, Holy Hell, Islam's Abuse of Women
and Infidels. who enable it. Um I mean
kudos for the title. I'm looking forward
to to reading that. That's a key issue
um in terms of what we face in terms of
women um and how we're being treated.
But and of course Jihadwatch, make sure
the viewers and listeners at Jihadwatch
RS make sure and follow Robert onx and
jihadwatch.org or the website uh with a
fantastic amount of information on the
geopolitical side but also on the purely
on the religious side. Um you'll it'll
be well worth your read. But Robert,
you're I mean your first time you wrote
a book was 2002
um called Islam Unveiled uh and
obviously following on from 9/11 uh
disturbing questions about the world's
fastest growing faith. Um you've got a
book coming up and I know you did work
behind the scenes in a decade or so
before that but your public side has
been uh in the last 22 years. Maybe if I
could ask you about where we are at the
moment in terms of discussion on Islam.
I'm wondering has America got to the
position where I guess critiquing Islam
is an acceptable conversation?
>> Oh, I don't think it's acceptable
anymore than it ever has been in the
United States. It might be a little bit
more because people are waking up to the
reality of what's happening uh as they
grow more aggressive. For example, in
Epic City, the uh East Plano Islamic
Center is attempting to create a Sharia
enclave in this area of Texas and that
has gotten a lot of notice. Uh there are
public displays such as uh Muslims
shutting down streets in Philadelphia or
blocking large areas of New York City
for public prayers. And this kind of
thing awakens people to what's
happening. But the American people like
the people in Britain and elsewhere have
been thoroughly propagandized now ever
since 9/11 very skillfully and
relentlessly with the idea that
Islamophobia is the real problem. Islam
is completely benign, peaceful, and to
be encouraged, and there's nothing
that's wrong with it. Anybody who thinks
that the terrorists have anything to do
with Islam, uh don't uh understand Islam
properly and the real thing is nothing
to be concerned about.
>> What about in the the media space? I
know you do many different interviews
and many different shows. Some of them
you'll be speaking to an audience who
already accepts the position that we
have an issue with Islam. Other
audiences may actually have never heard
it before. I mean what is um been your
experience in terms of engaging in the
media over those years.
>> It was a lot more open in the first few
years after 9/11. Then there were the
trauma was fresh and people were willing
to have this discussion. And so I was on
PBS and uh CNN several times and Fox of
course many times uh the BBC and uh many
others that would never have this
discussion today. And any time that
somebody like me, not just me, but
others as well, is on a mainstream
program of whatever kind, then the hosts
are inundated with protests as to how
you could have this terrible person.
It's as if what the left has decided and
the Islamic groups have decided is that
people like me can talk to people like
you and that's okay. But if I talk to
the BBC, which of course the BBC knows
not to do this anymore. As a matter of
fact, Peter, just as an aside, the last
time I was on the BBC was when I was
banned from Britain and I happened to be
working in the middle of the night
because I couldn't sleep. So, I was here
working and uh I saw the BBC announce on
Twitter at the time that they were about
to have a discussion of whether Pamela
Geller and I should be banned from
entering the UK. And so I wrote to them
on Twitter and said, "How can you have
this discussion with neither of us
participating?" And so they were shamed
into having me on. And that was the last
time. Now they know better. But uh in
any time that one of those media outlets
like that might consider carrying this
point of view, then they're inundated
with furious protests and demands for
equal time as if their their point of
view is not getting heard 99% of the
time as it is or more. uh and so uh yeah
there is a lot of media but it's only
the media that's open to this issue and
to discussing it honestly which is not
the mainstream media. What what about
one other thing I want to ask actually
never asked you is about your method of
delivery because if you look at someone
who shares all our concerns but puts it
forward in a very different way would be
Tommy Robinson and I think he sometimes
falls into the trap of being too
emotional and too in your face where you
deliver it in a way that's very gentle
and mild and people cannot get annoyed
at you because of your method of
delivery. They may get annoyed at the
material, but not about the method. I
mean, is that something you've learned
or are you just fairly chilled anyway?
>> Yeah, I've just never been like that. I
if if I wanted to be Tommy Robinson, I
couldn't. And so maybe I should have
worked harder at trying to be like that
because obviously he's an international
uh hero and somebody who everybody knows
and uh so maybe that was the way to go.
But I always have tried to and that's
not to take anything away from Tommy,
but I've always tried to portray put to
put forward what I am arguing on a
rational basis with evidence, which is
not to say that he doesn't have do that
or have it available, but in any case,
uh I'm trying to appeal to people on the
basis of reason. And one thing I've
learned over the last quarter century is
that people don't work on the basis of
reason. But now I'm an old man and it's
uh unlikely I'm going to learn any new
tricks.
>> Can I ask you about the political will
in America? Um your time on on speaking
uh I know that the revelation came out
goodness 15 years ago that some of your
books are being used by the FBI and of
course this was shock horror um and
immediately they were taken down. they
couldn't use anything by Robert Spencer.
But what about that political will to
actually confront Islam in the US has
have you seen any change in that either
at the local or the national level?
>> A small change and that is for example
the director of national intelligence
Tulsi Gabbard uh announced a few months
ago that they were going to be working
against radical Islamist terrorism. Now,
she knows to use this term because she
knows that it really Islam is completely
benign and has nothing to do with
terrorism and it's only this perversion
of it. But I'll take that actually
because that's a great improvement over
the last administration which repeatedly
insisted that white supremacism was the
biggest terror threat the nation faced.
There was no basis for that in reality,
but that's what they said. And so the
there there is no political will to face
the full reality of the problem.
Nobody's doing that anywhere along the
political spectrum. And as a matter of
fact, this has always been the problem
for me that people I've thought would
have been naturally allied and in line
with this point of view have thought
instead, well, we want to court Muslim
voters in the US. And so they don't uh
ally with this point of view. Not about
a year ago, I was speaking at a group in
California and
uh spoke to them about mosques and how
mosques are so often called Islamic
centers because
the
idea is that it's a center for da'wah,
Islamic proitizing, and ultimately for
jihad. And Americans need to know this
so that they realize that a mosque is
not just the equivalent of a church or
synagogue. It is a political entity that
has and that has implications in or
ought to for public policy. And there
was a local politician in the audience
who got up and started bragging about
how he had been the only Republican
candidate for whatever it was he was
running for to visit the local mosque
and to appeal to the Muslims to uh vote
Republican. And I thought, does this guy
not have any idea of the truth of what I
was just saying? Or does he not even
realize how he's being manipulated and
played by these people? But in any case,
that's the dominant main he represents
the dominant mainstream, not the
perspective that I was putting forward
>> and and that you mentioned to Gabber
talking about radical Islamist groups.
Um I mean I I can understand the word
radical because radical is about maybe
going back to your roots and and that is
the concern. Um the the I guess the the
best Muslim is one that's not radical
because they no understanding of their
history and they see this as a um as
maybe a cultural cloak. But in terms of
the terminology, I mean, Islamism is a a
fairly new word that's been used. Um,
and it's doesn't see it's this
distinction which I guess is safer
because you don't critique the religion,
you critique a branch of it that's not
really part of it. Um, and we are still
having that same falling over themselves
in terms of politicians talking about
Islam in the UK and Europe. And I I
probably think it's the same in the US.
It's a fear to call, as we say, call a
spade a spade. Call it out for what it
is.
>> Very much so, Peter. Look, uh you're
very generous really to say that radical
is going back to the root. And so that's
okay to that's a perfectly accurate uh
term to use because of course I don't
know maybe Tulsi Gabbard has studied
Latin and knows that radics means root
and that that's the root word for
radical in English. Uh maybe she knows
that but I suspect that she's using the
word in the more common understanding of
that these are the extremists. These are
the people who are far out who may be
twisting and hijacking the real thing.
Uh the whole idea of calling them
radical is to give the impression that
there is a benign core that is not
radical that we don't have to worry
about and those are the true Muslims and
then these people who are radical
they're the only ones that are the
problem and they're the fringe who are
twisting the thing. Uh the whole idea of
Islamism is the same. Islamism was
invented in the west. It does not exist
as a concept within Islam except as a
western import. The only reason why
people speak about Islamism at all is so
they don't have to speak about Islam.
They know that is or well they might not
know they they want to avoid giving the
impression whether out of knowledge or
intentional deception to protect
themselves and their professional career
or their political career. They want to
distinguish what they are criticizing
from Islam itself. The only problem with
that is that it is Islam itself that is
the source of these problems that
they're criticizing. They're pretending
that it's not, but it is.
>> That's we've seen across maybe to
politicians playing it safe. about then
the we haven't spoken since President
Trump um actually took office and I'm
curious to get your thoughts on where
the administration is going. Not that I
want to get you into trouble or
anything, but it I mean there there he
has so much on his plate, so many issues
that he has to deal with. And of course,
immigration, which people see as
separate from Islam, although it's all
very part of it, but immigration and the
economy um are really the the big ones
and maybe stopping wars abroad. And my
concern is that Islam isn't seen as an
issue or a threat by the administration.
And I don't know how you've seen over
the last 6 months the administration and
their approach to Islam.
>> Uh well, like I say, Tulsi Gabbert did
say that. Uh I haven't seen a whole lot
of action in that regard. Um Trump has
been disappointing. I don't know how it
could get me in trouble. I don't have
any promotions to the administration.
We're not arresting people for dissident
yet in the United States. Maybe uh I
mean I know that's going on in Britain
and I hope you stay out of trouble, but
uh in any case, so far I mean the Biden
regime would have loved to do that, but
they didn't quite get that far. Uh
Trump,
he's he he's not going to see this, but
if he were to see it, he might think,
well, I I don't like this guy, but it's
no skin off my nose. Anyway, he said uh
back in 20 goodness, was it 2015 or 16
August? It was right around this time. I
Oh, I believe it was 2016 and we just
had the ninth anniversary of him saying
in much the same way that Tulsi just did
that he was going to make sure he was
campaigning for his first term and said,
"We're we're not going to allow radical
Islam to gain a foothold in the United
States." Well, since then, he's changed.
He hasn't said anything like that ever
since. And in the 2024 election, he
boasted proudly about support he got
from imams in Michigan because they were
disgusted with the Democrat party's
embrace of all the gender madness and
all the far-left sexual fantasies and
delusions that they are so interested in
propagating and disseminating among the
wider population. And so a lot of
Muslims, this has been the the crack in
the left Islamic alliance and a lot of
Muslims voted for Trump as a result. And
I think perhaps in pursuit of that, he
has muted his criticism that he
previously had of what was essentially
the jihad. Um it doesn't seem as if
anybody has any clue about this on
either side. And you have uh on the one
side the left and the Democrats helping
the Islamic Republic of Iran and old Joe
Biden after October 7th sending millions
of dollars to Hamas. That is and he
said, "No, no, no. It's humanitarian aid
to Gaza." Well, that means to Hamas
because who else is going to who's who
in Gaza is going to get the humanitarian
aid and keep it out of the hands of
Hamas? Obviously, no one. So, he's
funding Hamas. He's funding the Islamic
Republic of Iran. He sends them 20
billion dollars in un unfrozen funds
that were they belonged to the sha and
every president since Jimmy Carter has
kept them in anticipation of giving it
back to a more humane regime in Iran.
And Biden after October 7th when it's
clear that the Iranians are funding this
jihad against Israel, he sends them $20
billion. So the United States
funded the jihad against Israel. So
Trump comes in and we think all that's
going to stop. Great. It did stop. But
he's pals with Qatar. What's Qatar? The
Muslim Brotherhood. The Hamas leaders
hiding out cheering October 7th from
from watching it on video fromQatar.
So out of the frying pan into the fire.
And uh I'm sorry to see it, but
at a certain point you have to take the
advice of Padre Peio. Pray hope and
don't worry. Just keep going and telling
the truth and hope that it will someday
come out. But Peter, it does mystify me
that you have I mean I wrote a book back
in 2018, The History of Giad, and it was
kind of depressing to write, tell you
the truth. I think it's a it's it's a
good book. I'm proud of it and I think
it's an important book because there
isn't any other history of jihad out
there and it's for but it's 1400 years
of the advance of Islam with very little
push back
and I don't get how I mean of course
most people don't know that history
that's why the book was necessary to
write but
how is it that this foe of the west for
over well over a millennium can suddenly
become something you're not allowed to
criticize in the West and you're not
allowed to point out that it was the foe
of the West for over a millennium and
has not changed since then in its
theology or goals. It it mystifies me.
>> Um I think the book I would like to
write maybe as a comedy fairy tale would
be Gays for Gaza. I think it would be
quite a a fun book. Maybe a a comic
strip or something
book. Hey kids, time to off the roof.
>> Stupidity. Um you you mentioned Muslim
Brotherhood and I've seen what recently
with Rubio talking about um Muslim
Brotherhood being a prescribed
organization and of course in the UK and
parts of Europe I mean and London many
Islamic organizations operate in London
with impunity that are actually banned
in in many parts of the world. Uh and
the Muslim Brotherhood have got their
their tentacles in all different
organizations.
Um what is like there in the US? Will
did I hear um Rubio correctly saying
that they're going to move to to ban
that? How will that work? Is that um
will that be a positive thing? What were
your thoughts whenever that came out?
>> Well, I'm certainly glad to hear it, but
here again, let's see what happens.
There's been talk about this for all
these years. Where is the action? And
it, as it happens, Muslim Brotherhood
linked operatives are embedded
throughout the US government. And they
they have prevented it from happening
thus far. And I noticed that it's been
now a little while, not too long, but
it's been a little while since this was
first brooded about in this
administration, and nothing's happened.
I'm not holding my breath here because
there are indeed very powerful forces
that don't want it to happen. and the
Council on American Islamic Relations
for all the evil that they represent
have been a very skillful and effective
organization in the US. Maybe it's just
money driven that they buy these people
off, but they have lots of allies in
high places. And lots of politicians
want to have a photo leftist politicians
and even some idiot conservative
politicians want to have photo ops with
these people and think they'll get the
Muslim vote or whatever. like that guy
that was at my talk in California. And
uh this is something that then care and
its allies cash in on. They go back to
these politicians and they say, "We need
a favor. We need you to vote against any
action against the Muslim Brotherhood.
And if you do, we'll deliver the
district to you next year, the Muslim
vote, and that could make the difference
between winning and losing." Okay. Yes,
sir.
This is how it works in America. I'm
sure it works to to a great degree the
same way in many areas of Britain and
all over Europe. And so this is uh the
big problem that we face and dealing
with this issue that for 20ome years now
these people have been embedded in the
US government uh infiltrating
everywhere, gaining influence, gaining
friends, gaining power. It's not going
to be that easy just to say, "Okay, this
is banned now. You you got to pack up
and go home." It's going to be very
difficult.
Can I Another issue in the UK and I'm
curious how it's impacted the US is with
the the war in Gaza and that was used by
a lot of politicians on the left in the
last general election in the UK a year
ago. Um I think we now have 21 or 22
Muslim MPs up from 16 before. I think we
have more Muslim MPs in the UK than any
other country in Europe, although I'd
have to triple check that. But, um, I
wonder how in the US, how is that that
war, how is that acted in terms of the
left and being able to drive the vote?
And obviously I know you've got the
concern in New York of what may happen
there, but kind of wider than that, has
has what's been happening in Israel and
Gaza, has that been a a potential boost
or political boost to politicians in the
US?
>> A boost,
>> a boost to those from the left. So it it
it drove the agenda very much so when
you had Labor politicians saying they
were standing for Gaza as opposed to
standing for their own constituents. and
they seem to care more about that and
has that kind of trickled into um the US
political scene in terms of
electioneering
>> very much so. Yeah. All over the place
top to bottom. You take for example last
year the presidential election and uh
Kla Harris suddenly becomes the
candidate for the Democrats and has to
choose a vice presidential candidate and
the big contender was supposedly
Governor Shapiro of Pennsylvania who was
then rejected at least reportedly
because he was Jewish and because she
did not want to antagonize the
increasingly
influential and vocal pro Hamas wing of
the Democrat party and so she chose this
uh this fool Tim Waltz and ended up
going down in flames. But uh not to say
she wouldn't have lost with Shapiro as
well. Probably the Rashida Tleb Ilhan
Omar Alexandria Oasio Okasiocortez
wing of the Democrat party would have
bolted and refused to support the
ticket. So that's what she wanted to
head off. But uh that's just one thing.
There are many other politicians who've
come out seeing the way the wind is
blowing come out in favor of uh a
ceasefire at very least or have
denounced Israel for some bogus thing or
other because they want the votes. And
the Muslim vote is increasingly
important in the United States as it is
in Britain as the mass migration
continues. Um, and what people don't
understand in Britain or the United
States is because Islam is a political
entity as well as a religious one. And
supremacist and and expansionist as well
as political,
the Muslims immediately when they come
to a new country are going to seek
political power and are always going to
have political power because they seek
it out of proportion to their numbers.
And so you have 21 or whatever it was
Muslim MPs and probably the Muslim
population doesn't really justify that.
But you've got people who vote in a as a
block for any Muslim candidate because
they understand that it is imperative
for them as a Muslim to increase the
political power of the Muslims.
And it's the same thing in the United
States as well that uh they seek
political power, they get political
power and wield political power in a way
that makes other groups bend to their
will. And yet nobody seems to be aware
of this. And anybody who hears me
talking about this and is not aware of
it already is going to say, "Oh, this
guy's a racist, bigoted Islamophobe."
But it's really just the lessons of
history here.
>> No, of course. I I want to look at some
other areas in in Europe that we've seen
and get your thoughts on where the US
fits. Um, and you've obviously seen a
massive demographic change in uh over in
the UK and Europe with mass immigration.
I think the UK is around 6% Muslim
population. The US is probably just over
1% if figures are correct. I think you
have 2,500
2,600 mosques. We have around 2,000 and
the UK are a fifth to size. So, um, the
US are behind in terms of that
thankfully. Um, but even in a in a read
here an article last year by Fitch
Ratings, the the ratings company that
gives that the AAA ratings if you've got
a good economy and it said the UK
remains a western hub for the Islamic
finance industry. London Stock Exchange
is the third largest listing for US
dollar suks globally um with 35% global
share. Why the UK has got 35% global
share of the suk market? Um but and it
goes into other areas and I'm wondering
the US is much further behind in terms
of Islamic banking really in terms of
halal food um which are both kind of
economic jihad is behind in terms of
demographics. Um and I'm wondering does
that mean that maybe the US don't see
Islam as a concern? I mean they see it
as a European problem but not a US
problem. Is that part of the problem
with this conversation?
Yeah, but uh
yeah, it's it's also that they don't
think of it as a problem at all. That
you say they see it as a European
problem and not a US problem. really
that's a function of their
misapprehension of the whole issue such
that they see that the US has a problem
with immigration from the south from the
southern border of of Spanishspeaking
people who are coming from Mexico and
South America and Europe has a problem
of immigration of Muslims coming from
North Africa and the Middle East and so
they see it as a problem of immigration
which it is but as far as it being a
problem of Islam itself very few people
have any idea of that in the US
mainstream they they would think that
here again it's racist and bigoted and
Islamophobic to think such a thing so
when you're talking about Sharia finance
it's the same problem people think of it
as a series of accommodations that they
can make that are uh completely valuable
and unimportant and just a uh a matter
of cultural sensitivity that will open
up to them this massive new market and
the connection between
Sharia finance and terrorism or Muslim
Brotherhood linked pro-sharia
organizations.
They don't know or care about any of
that. in Britain or the US.
>> I mean, how big is is the halal market?
I mean, when I'm in London, most high
streets I go down in London, the
majority of takeaway shops um are halal
only because you don't get a choice cuz
it's much easier for them to have one
supplier and one preparation area. But,
um and often the the bigger restaurants
are going halal um and it has a mark any
chicken, anything you buy and often they
don't have poor products. I mean, and
we've come to just accept that as the m
as the the sign of multiculturalism.
That's wonderful. It shows how tolerant
we are. I I don't know if the halal
industry has kind of forced its way as
much into the US.
Yeah, it's very bad. See, you know, this
is the situation of people demanding
something and insisting on it and the
other people on the other side don't
care. So, they give them what they want
here again without realizing the
implications. And so, you have the
Muslims saying, "We want to have we have
to have halal meat and we won't eat
anything else." And the non-Muslims say,
"We don't even know what halal is. We
don't care." So, all the meat becomes
halal. And this is far more extensive
than most people realize.
The as a matter of fact about back when
I was doing a lot of activism with
Pamela Geller about 15 years ago, uh we
discovered that a great deal of meat was
being sold in the United States that was
halal but was not labeled as such
because the people who were selling it
figured nobody cares. the Muslims care,
so we'll give them what they want, but
nobody else cares. And so, if like you
said, it's easier not to have two
different uh places for preparing
everything. They just make everything
halal. So, we actually got an
appointment and went to Washington and
spoke with people in the Department of
Agriculture and the Food and Drug
Administration and they agreed that
there were indeed people in the United
States who did care and did not want to
eat halal because they didn't want to
have uh their money going to halal
butchers and having that whole
connection with Muslim Muslim
Brotherhood linked organizations which
is pretty much every Muslim group in the
US and they might have disagreements
based on the method of halal slaughter
which is very inhumane.
So animal rights activists who are not
total vegetarians might object to halal
and so on. And all these officials we
spoke to they said yes yes very
important points we will review all this
and get back to you. And then they went
totally dead and we made repeated
inquiries and they ignored us and the
issue that was it. And so as far as I
know there's no reason not to think that
most of the meat or a good deal of the
meat sold in the United States is still
halal and it's not being labeled as such
and people have no idea.
>> Yeah, we still have that in the UK in
terms of many supermarkets. It's still a
huge issue and no one seems to care. Um
can I touch on your book that you've
coming up and again holy hell Islam's
abuse of women that's one side and the
infidels who enable it. Um in terms of
the the west the weak liberals accepting
this as as positive and those are two
very separate parts I think to that
massive concern. And I I know you'll
talk about the grooming gangs that have
happened to the Muslim rape gangs or
Muslim Pakistani rape gangs or the
Indian rape guide, however they're
called to try and get away from what the
problem is. But I I think Sweden is the
only other country that actually the
media
has raised a concern of these rape gangs
happening and Sweden is has utterly
collapsed. But I mean two things. one,
we're told this comes from a just a
tribe in Pakistan, so this is tribal and
this certainly isn't religious and
that's why the media are happy to call
it Pakistani grooming gangs and
certainly not Muslim. But want to get
your thoughts on that, but also I I
can't believe this is only happening in
two countries of the world. So what are
your thoughts on the prevalence of this
elsewhere?
>> Uh Peter, it's happening all over. I
have it in the book. I have information.
Of course, there's a great deal of the
book is about the UK, but also there is
Sweden, Germany, France, Italy, and
elsewhere, Australia.
It's happening all over where there is
Muslim migration. The reason why it's
happening where there is Muslim
migration is because it is something
that is based on Islamic teaching. And
nobody wants to talk about that. Even
still, even after all the controversy
you've had in Britain over it over all
these years and Elon Musk reigniting the
controversy last year, which was the
impetus for my writing this book, and
the Starmer government saying, "No,
we're not going to have a national
inquiry, and there's still all this
pressure. So, finally, they have to
relent and say they'll have a national
inquiry." And I expect it'll just be
another cover up. But in any case, uh,
nobody in all of this controversy has
wanted to say the truth
except for Tommy and a few others. But
you take for example, and I discuss her
in the book, the case of Sarah Champion,
who was I, as far as I know, she's still
an MP, I don't know, but she was the
shadow when the conservatives were in
power, she was a shadow labor minister
for something or other. and she said
back in 2017 that most of the rapists in
these gangs were Pakistani
and there was a huge firestorm and she
and Labour booted her out of the shadow
cabinet and she had to apologize
and yet most of the people in these
gangs were Pakistani
and they weren't even doing but and and
see the thing about this Peter
is on the one hand she's great great and
courageous and on the other hand she's a
total coward because
she stood up to them enough to say this
truth that they are Pakistani but then
she backed down when she got pressure
and
she didn't even come close to the real
problem the real problem was not that
they're Pakistani
they could have been Somali they could
have been Arab they could have been
anything Because the problem is rooted
in Islamic theology and the idea that if
a woman goes out and she's not veiled,
the Quran in chapter 33:59
says that a woman should pull the veil
over her bosom because then she will not
be molested. Which the the hidden
subtext there, the unspoken corollary is
that if you do not veil, you can be
molested.
And then you've got of course all the
theology of the captives of the right
hand in the Quran that makes it very
clear that Muslim men can take
non-Muslim women as sex slaves.
So Muslim men come from Pakistan to
Britain
and they see all these unveiled women.
And of course also because they're
unveiled,
they've been taught back home and in
their communities in Britain, these
women are all and they all want
to have sex with you. All you have to do
is grab them and go. And so they do.
And they think this is something that
Allah calls for in the Quran. And so
it's a holy act. It's like a sacrament.
It's not a a a vicious dirty crime like
we assume it to be in the west. And
that's why you have the rape gangs
consisting of a father and a son
and uncles and brothers because they
don't see anything wrong with this. I in
the United States. If some guy is a
rapist, he's going to try to hide it
from everybody around him. not just for
fear of arrest but for the shame of it.
And he knows that his family would be
ashamed if it turns out that he's a
rapist. But in but in the Muslim culture
because of these teachings of the Quran,
what's to be ashamed of? This is what
these infidel women are for. This is
what Allah, the perfect God says
in the Quran, the perfect book.
And so what do they have to be ashamed
of? Everybody join in.
And so you even have wives
helping the husbands do this because
it's just the way men are. And it's
Allah knows this. Allah made the men.
Allah made the women. He made the
infidel women. That's what they're for.
But nobody will talk about it. Nobody
talks about it in Britain. Uh, I can't
go. Other people who talk about it can't
go to Britain. Not not a coincidence.
Uh, the people who do talk about it like
Tommy are viciously persecuted by the
state.
The only people who are in the
mainstream who will talk about it don't
come close to the truth about it like
Sarah Champion. And they still get
trouble for even getting closer than
most people are going to. And so it's a
very bad situation. You've got an entire
society that seems resolute in its
refusal to face the reality of this.
Because of course if the British people
as an whole knew
that the government, successive
governments, both conservative and
labor,
they brought these people in
and they let them do this because once
they brought them in, they were afraid
that they would lose elections if they
admitted that they'd made a big mistake
and if they said, "We've got to stop
this." And so they they don't nobody
stops it. Everybody says, "Oh, we're
going to stop this." And they don't stop
it
and they keep coming.
And if they say, "We're going to stop
this," then the obvious next question
is, "Why have you allowed it to happen
in the first place?" And then they lose
entirely any any any credibility that
they have as people who should be
governing a state. So the whole
establishment is now committed to this
to save itself.
And this is why Britain is done for. I'm
sorry. I love you guys,
but it's over. I I don't see how you're
going to survive as a free society. Now,
maybe there will be some new glorious
revolution of 1688 uh happening yet
again and the uh miscreants will be
booted out of the government. But then
you've got the mess they've created over
the last 30 years going to be very hard
to deal with. What are you going to do?
Deport people who are citizens who've
grown up there and know that they're
acting completely within their rights as
a law gave them the right to take these
infidel women. This is it's a it's a
it's a very very difficult situation.
>> It is. And we one or two points in that
that I know you pick up on as we finish.
um you see the closer you get to power
the less you want to engage with this
and we see that with reform party uh
with Nigel Farage and he has now rolled
back massively um and basically Muslims
as voters as opposed to having a clash
between the freedoms we have in the west
you see them rolling back and then this
this it kind of becomes entertainment in
some perverse way newspapers have it
they publish a story and they talk about
it for a few days. The BBC does whole
shows about this. Um, you've got all
party parliamentary groups on honorbased
abuse and they invite these girls and
they listen to them. People get books
published. It kind of becomes like a a a
some perverse media industry. Um, and
then they move on to the next and it's
diabolical.
>> It's uh salacious stories about sex
sells papers. It's the it's a it's an
old thing. you know, going back, I don't
know if The Sun still has the topless
women on page three, was it? And I I
remember reading about that and
thinking, gee, that's terrible. That
paper's out there. Any kid can pick it
up. And that was what 30ome years ago
they started doing that or longer. And
uh this kind of thing sells papers. And
so you have this steady stream of
stories that are along the same lines.
Yeah, they're going to get a lot of
publicity, but nobody really dares to
act because you've got this growing
constituency that is uh uh
increasingly wielding political power
and nobody wants to cross them.
>> Absolutely. Can I just one last point?
Um want to just touch on Israel. People
talk about Israel being the problem and
actually if Israel wasn't there then
actually you might suddenly have a
peaceful Islam because the issue is
against Israel. um as if Islam doesn't
have a problem uh with with the West and
and that's a a narrative that's
certainly been repeated in the media
certainly um since October the 7th
attack and and long before then um that
the the blockage to peace is Israel. Um
maybe just remind the audience that if
Israel didn't exist then Islam wouldn't
become peaceful overnight.
>> Yeah, I'm afraid that's the case, Peter.
As you know, the imperatives to make war
against and subjugate unbelievers do not
apply only to Israel or to the Jews, but
are general against all unbelievers. The
Quran says, for example, in chapter
8:39, "Fight until persecution is no
more." And if it stopped there, you
could justify saying, "Oh, jihad's only
defensive," as the apologists like to
say. But it doesn't stop there. It says,
"Fight them until persecution is no more
and religion is all for Allah." So you
could be minding your own business or I
could be minding my own business, never
bothering them at all, never criticizing
Islam. And if my religion is not all for
Allah, then there are still going to be
some Muslims someday who think we need
to fight that guy. We need to fight all
of them whose religion is not for Allah.
So if people actually think that if
Israel were to disappear then there
would be peace. They have no
understanding of Islamic theology. And
actually if Israel were to disappear,
which God forbid, then the jihadis would
be more emboldened than ever, and would
be coming after the West with increased
virolence. Not that they're not coming
after the West already.
>> No, absolutely. Um Robert, always
appreciate you coming on and and
certainly for the viewers and listeners.
Um you do such a wide range of books
last year uh Muhammad a critical
biography uh the one on women holy hell
coming up later this year but also
general ones and I think it's fantastic
the options and the availability and the
knowledge of given that people can
actually go on a specific topic or get
one of the books which are more general.
So I've encouraged the the viewers and
listeners to go and make sure on
jihadwatch.org or um just put Robert's
name in uh in Google in in Amazon um and
take a pick pick one that sounds
interesting to you uh because I know you
will be blessed reading it and and be
better informed. So, Robert, thank you
as always for giving us your time.
>> Always good to talk to you, Peter. Thank
you.
If you like what we do, sign up to our
mailing list, donate, share, and
subscribe to our many platforms at
hearts of oak.org.
Thank you for listening.